leaving afghanistan doesn't mean
afghanistan leaves then
soldiers who served like stuart pearson
and families who waited back home like
bob and jim
wright the parents of mark i used to say
well but if you go out
any and there's any trouble hide behind
the biggest tree
i'm in afghanistan mum there's no any
big trees
we've got a man marking stewart's
horrific story has been graphically
depicted on the big screen
even impossible due to location being
minefield
with colleagues the two friends became
trapped in a minefield
after going in to help a fellow soldier
who'd stood on a mine
or four explosions the second took off
stewart's left leg
i took my foot off a rock my left foot
and put it on the ground and that's when
i
that's when i heard the explosion um i
get
blown up slightly and twisted round
the soldiers have called for a
helicopter with a winch to lift out
casualties and relative safety
but they were told none was available
the downdraft from a landing chinook
set off another might
unfortunately mark who was struggling
over me protecting me from the
the down blast of the helicopter he got
blasted
by that injuries to his face neck and
upper body
mark wright survived the first explosion
that caught him he was
badly injured but continued to
communicate on the radio
and with critically injured colleagues i
remember just lying here thinking i
don't know if i can hold on for another
hour here
um but mark wasn't i was wanting to fall
asleep but mark wouldn't let anyone
fall asleep he was shouting at us after
four hours u.s
black hawk helicopters arrived at the
site near afghanistan's kajaki dam
and winched the casualties to safety
four mines had injured eight soldiers
mark wright was hit twice as mark was
getting
winced up by the blackhawks and then
shouted down tell jolene and my family
that i love them
every night when he was waiting before
he went to sleep always here i love you
i always thought if i'm dead in the
morning absolutely that was the last
words i heard
and i mean when you used to phone he
always says bye i love you
i thought that crashed that's over then
i looked upside my mark was
lying there and i looked again and
paramedics were rolling on top of him
gave him cpr
and then i looked again at him and he
was gone
just took the breath away i just thought
that's our life over
at the inquest into mark wright's death
the coroner called him an exceptional
soldier
whose death was down to a series of
failures a lack of appropriate uk
helicopters
with a winch the downdraft from the
chinook
and the delay in sending an appropriate
helicopter
i'd say a lot of these decisions are
just made by there may be people who
sits in whitehall that have never
fought a battle at all taking one day
and uh fought an enemy so
um quite you know quite a quite
disgusting bite yeah
why did they go there in the first place
everywhere they go they never seem to
finish the job
and that's pulling out what about these
lives that were lost
sad james matthews
sky news dal keith